[music]
us from tasogare
galle ander pou dou
[music]
dou4th generation to
form figure 1 special wing ed
[music]
[music
] n My
name is c Kunihiko My occupation is
producing and manufacturing konnyaku
Konnyaku
may not look very appetizing, but it's
a food that all Japanese people love.
Konnyaku doesn't have
the eight Asian flavors of sweet, salty, or
spicy,
but
Pretty Cure Quiz you.
Do Tsuto Konnyaku Cuisine My favorite
way to eat it is by dipping it in konnyaku
soup and then picking up konnyaku frites.
minute jr this
powder even flight rt
Lowrys dark roots spent
voodoo The period of time in the warehouse is also very long
and I'm driving in that
quiet driving Seeing the quiet driving
I want konjacs to relax more
Music  To be
honest, I can't tell from human sounds or senses whether there was any change in the conversation after the music was played
.
[Music]
Boo Boo
Dubi Process
Spoonware worship you do Wig
Straight ran Diddy for
win Porting voices
are you doing
Konnyaku potato
Eating without processing
Eh  The
main thing is eight needle-shaped crystals.
To make
attractive things necessary
for customers
I want you to know
yeah yeah yeah me